hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com today we're going to
be looking at game 10 from the 2014
world chess championship between the
reigning champion magnus carlson and
vicia non the challenger now up until
this point madness carlson is up one
game we have three games remaining games
10 11 and 12. vishyana gets to play
white two more times so in game 10 the
game we're going to be going over today
and game 12 so he gets to end on whites
but he definitely needs a victory either
in this one or the last one it's
probably too crazy to expect him to get
a victory when he plays black against
magnus carlsen in game 11. so this match
today is extremely important for him he
needs to come out very aggressive try
some crazy moves to catch magnus
crossing off guard like he did in the
third game and so that's what we're
going to be looking at today so again
vishy non playing the white pieces
magnus crossing playing the black pieces
so vicious you can imagine started with
pawn to d4 as he has this entire
tournament knight to f6 we've kind of
seen this pawn to c4 madness crossing
throne is for a little loop plays pawn
here to g6 up into this point he would
kind of been sticking with that pawn
here to e6 and then either playing pawn
here to b6 for the queen's indian or
just coming down for the queen's
gambit's decline line with pawn here to
d5 so change it up quite a bit with pawn
here to g6 and now knight to c3 don't
have to worry about that nimzo indian
defense after pawn to e6 uh then upon
here to a d5 magnus crossing going into
the grunfeld defense so a very nice
solid defense again magnus crossing all
he really needs to do is draw he's up a
game with only three games to go in the
series so he's not trying to do anything
he's looking for this most solid defense
that he can possibly find bishop on the
other hand again needs to be pretty
aggressive knight here to f3 bishop to
g7 fiance this bishop trying to control
this long dark square diagonal and then
bishop on can go many different ways he
decides to go for the russian system
which is pretty interesting because if
you kind of look at magnus carlsen's
games from his entire career he's really
only played against the russian system
twice and that was almost 10 years ago
so although he hasn't played against it
he's very familiar with it he does play
the grunfeld quite a bit uh but it will
be interesting to see
how both sides have prepared for this
obviously vishyanan playing this he is
this is his go-to he thinks he has a
slight advantage in this so it'll be
interesting to see how magnus carson
will defend against queen to b3
one thing this does right away is it
pretty much forces black to take here on
c4 all the pressure building up with the
queen the pawn the knight here all on
the square on d5
black pretty much
needs to go ahead and take here on c4
white's going to recapture here on c4
and this is a few things one it opens up
a semi-open file for this rook to come
here to see one at any given time
white definitely has control of the
center which again if you're playing for
black as a hyper modern defense you're
willing to give up that control the
center so that you can try to counter
attack with your minor pieces and then
only later will you start to push
forward with your pawns but white
although he is very aggressive usually
his queen can get chased around if he
tries to stay too much in the center of
the board so he has a very active
position but definitely needs to make
sure that he doesn't get his queen out
too far uh because he doesn't want to
give up his powerful pieces so far
magnus crosston he learned from game
three where bishop kind of ran over him
with his queen if he can trade off
queens he knows he can get down to a
very drastic end game very very quickly
sufficient on is trying to avoid that we
see castle on the king side pawn here to
e4 and then magnus crossing now has a
few different options as far as the
russian system there's three main ways
you can approach this one is pawn to a6
they call this the hungarian variation
another one is to get the light square
bishop out involved so bishop to
g4 is very popular
and then later you can start to push
forward with pawn here to e6 but only
after you get this light square bishop
involved into the game and the last one
is knight to a6 and this is the prince
variation very popular with kasparov
when he played karpov in the world
championships
many years ago and you know it's
probably no surprise kasparov and magnus
carlsen studied this game chess together
many many times they're very close
friends so magnus crosston decided to
play this knight to e a6 which opens up
the door for
black to push forward with pawn here to
c5 later on again he's probably studied
this many times with kasparov bishop
here to e2 getting ready to castle on
the king side and then pawn pushing
forward to c5 as we talked about now the
pawns can push up to d5 wants to stay as
active as possible doesn't want to go
ahead and exchange right off the board
and then pawn here to e6 getting ready
to exchange we now see castle on the
king side and then pawn taking here on
d5 so
again hyper modern defense trying to
control getting your minor pieces and
then only then counter attacking and
destroy the board that's exactly what
magnus carlsen is trying to do here so
pawn here to d5 gonna be an important
pawn the rest of the way white's gonna
look to get his rooks behind this start
to push forward if he can
even push this to the seventh rank and
maybe put pressure on his opponent to
get a pass pawn that's going to be very
very dangerous for magnus carlsen so he
has to keep an eye on that for right now
he osto has to keep an eye on his
pawn here on c5 he doesn't want to have
to tie up his knight here on a6 to hold
control of this you never want your
knights on the edge you want them in the
center of the board to control more of
the board so he's going to be looking
for an alternative to control the square
here on c5 we see the rook over here to
e8 uh trying to just control these open
files that's always where you want your
rooks to go and then bishop here to g5
pinning this knight down to the queen
carlson now plays pawn to h6 forcing
this bishop to come back bishop here to
e3 still very active square for this
bishop controlling the center and again
attacking that small weakness for black
with his pawn over here on a c5 now this
bishop is going to come down here to f5
again just trying to complete
development getting all the minor pieces
to control the center of the board kind
of what both sides are looking to do
here look over here to d1 trying to
centralize this rook as well you always
want it's behind your pawn so you can
kind of push those pawns
forward that's going to be very good and
then a novelty here up into this point
this is variation has been seen before
but usually black would continue with
queen to b6
and then from here you may see rook here
to d2 controlling this pawn here on b2
but we see our first novelty so the
russian system in the grenfell defense
you don't see it all the time and so you
we're starting to see a few different
moves which is always exciting and
madness carlson plays knight to e4 so a
little bit more aggressive than even the
queen to b6 is kind of they play out uh
but knight to e4
it's tough to say if vichy anon was
prepared for it he did play pretty
quickly but magnus cross and you could
definitely tell although he doesn't play
against the russian system he was very
confident in his moves and he was ready
for this knight to e4 move
we now see vishyanan take here on e4 we
now see the bishop take white now does
have a double bishop here which is going
to be always good this queen's going to
come back here to c1 very good move i
think from vishyanan it does a lot of
things one it's a discovered attack with
this bishop here on a6 if you know
bishonon could take this knight and then
magnus carlsen's forced to retake with
his pawn here uh double pawns on the a
file or even the h file are just
terrible you can't do much at all it's
almost just having one pawn
so that's going to be very good also
putting a lot of pressure on his
opponent to play bishop to
h6 since he does have his queen behind
here so
it's very difficult for magnus carlsen
to defend well i think queen to f6 which
he played is probably the best it not
only defends the square here on a6 but
if his opponent does play h6 he can
actually force his opponent to trade off
queens and that's what happens in the
game bishon on takes here on h6 and then
the queen comes down here to b2
pretty much forcing his opponent's hand
to go ahead and exchange so we do see an
exchange now the bishop come back here
to too and as we discussed just a few
minutes ago that's what magnus crossing
wants to do he's trying to exchange off
all the material if they could draw
right now magnus carlsen would
immediately do that he doesn't want to
try to do anything too crazy definitely
doesn't want his opponent to have an
active queen that's the only game that
he's lost in this entire series is game
number three when bishonon kind of ran
rapid with his queen so he is ecstatic
at this point to go ahead and go down in
material and so that's pretty much what
he's going to be looking to do the rest
of the game now we see knight here to g5
and magnus crossing took a long time
20 plus minutes after this move he he
said after the press conference he
wasn't expecting this move he thought it
was a very active move from vishy and on
and so he definitely didn't want to mess
up because he said if he made any wrong
moves in the next four to five moves it
was going to be devastating for him i
think he did end up with the best move
and he played bishop here to d4 and this
does a lot of things one it centralizes
your bishop which is always what you
want to do it puts it on a nice outpost
so it's defended by this pawn here on c5
his opponent has a dark square here on
h6 it's going to be very difficult to
attack this you you don't want to
exchange off with your rook just because
you'll go down material but another
thing it does it blocks off protection
from this rook here on d1 on this pawn
so now he can start to attack he can get
his knight involved into the game since
it it now has another defender with this
bishop here on d4
this knight can get involved this bishop
here on e4 can also attack this pawn
also the rook can swing over here to d8
and start to attack this pawn here as
well so uh magnus crossing fantastic
fine you know if we kind of look at we
say oh yeah you know it's pretty easy
just centralize your bishop and find an
outpost but he did have many different
options but i definitely think he found
the best one here
bishon decided to go ahead and take this
bishop here on e4 recognizing that it's
just putting a lot of pressure on this
pawn and since he no longer has the
projection from his rook he just didn't
want to have to deal with it he could
have played bishop here to c4 it seems a
little bit too passive just to try to
hold on to this pawn and just pretty
much give up any attacking prowess that
this bishop here has could have also
maybe even tried bishop to
b5 attacking this rook but that's just
kind of an in-between move after the
rook moves all of a sudden his pawns
going to be under attack again so
decided he didn't want to have to deal
with that just plays knight taking here
on e4 then the rook's going to swing
down here to e4 take and then bishop to
f3 now the good thing is uh
magnus crosstalk no longer has a bishop
pair so as long as vishyanan can keep
this board open he does have the bishop
pair that's going to be good in an open
game bishops definitely do better in
open game because they have more squares
that they can control over the board so
bishonon definitely has that going form
now the roots can swing up back here to
e7 uh and then the pawn pushes forward
here to d6 vishyanan he needs to open up
this d file that's very important for
him right now this bishop on d4 is just
kind of annoying for him
but he does want to kind of open this up
and then push forward and if he can get
it further it could be very very
detrimental for madness crossing now the
rook over here to d7 all this is doing
just kind of slowing that down it's
going to be very difficult for vishy non
to push past that he could always bring
his bishop here to g4 but then just rook
back here to d8 there's no way to really
stop both of those as well knight here
to a b4 more of an active square from
here and then if we look at it
we see the rook up here to a d2
defending the square here on a2 rook
over here to e8 trying to control this
long foul right here rook over here to
c1 again just both sides trying to find
any small advantage that they can this
rook starting to attack this pawn here
on c5
and then pawn here or excuse me rook
here to e6 attacking this pawn uh and
then pawn to push forward over here on
h4 trying to attack on the king side
it's going to be very very difficult for
vishyanan to actually find an opening
right here but that's kind of what he's
going for now magnus crossing decides
now is the time to go ahead and start
exchanging material off the board and he
would only do this bishop here to e5
opening up this d file if he thought he
could start to exchange material but
that's exactly you know what happened
it's very difficult for bishonon to do
anything else besides exchange so after
we see this exchange right here now a
pretty interesting move in the match for
vishy and on he decided to go and take
with his bishop here on b7 if you look
at you may say okay he's exchanging his
bishop to this pawn on b7 and then the
rook's just going to take it why would
he do that he's going to go down in
material
and he does but he gets that back
unfortunately to get it back he has to
exchange off a lot of material and go to
a drawlish in game he could have always
tried for something else as i kind of
analyze it i
you know there's not a ton of great
moves but i do like pawn here to a3 it
almost forces the knight to come back
here to c6 and then if you see an
exchange you do get to an end game but
all of a sudden you see double pawns
here on the c file so i think a slight
advantage to white in this scenario but
it is going to be very very difficult to
actually take that and convert it into a
win
but vishyanan decided to play bishop
taking here on b7 and the rook take it
as you can imagine but then the pawn
pushing forward here to d7 so
threatening the queen up here on d8
madness carlson only has one move that's
not here to c6 and then after the
promotion we do see an exchange right
here
but this is a drawn in game there's no
real way for either side to do too much
uh they're equal in material and
again
neither player in a million years could
potentially lose this and so after just
two more moves both players decide to go
ahead and draw uh get ready for the day
off tomorrow so
again if you're a madness crossing fan
you've got to feel pretty good about
this another draw you only have two more
games to dodge if you can draw both of
those you're going to be the champion
once again and you're going to be
champion for for two more years since we
don't have a world championship next
year if you're in the vicio non camp
you've got to be a little disappointed
that you couldn't find any advantage to
take advantage of and come out with a
win you do have one more game with
whites going until the 12th game which
could be
super epic if bishonon can find a win in
that case if magnus carlsen wins the
next game though it is all over so
that's going to be exciting but
hopefully you guys enjoyed i definitely
thought there was more fireworks than
this one the last one which only was
like 20 moves and it didn't look like
anyone wanted to play madness carlson
just defended extremely well showed why
he is the chess champion so thanks for
watching and i'll see you guys in the
next video